ja erstmal Hallo in die Runde ich freue
mich sehr über diese Einladung mein Name
ist Elisabeth zecker und ich bin
Geschäftsführerin der
Unterhaltungssoftware Selbstkontrolle
und freue mich sehr heute was zum Thema
Ethik Games und über die USK zu erzielen
vielleicht mal kurz zur Gliederung
meines Vortrags was habe ich mir für
heute vorgenommen was ich Ihnen erzählen
möchte natürlich erstmal die Grundlagen
des Jugendmedienschutzes warum gibt es
eigentlich Jugendmedienschutz wo kommen
wir daher und vor allem wo gehen wir hin
was ist die Unterhaltungssoftware
Selbstkontrolle was sind unsere Aufgaben
wofür sind wir zuständig und dann geht's
auch schon ganz eingemachte nämlich zu
den Leitkriterien der USA also sprich
die Bewertungskriterien die bei Computer
und Videospielen angelegt werden bis hin
über die Themen Spruchpraxis also
Entscheidungen über die Zeit und
natürlich auch so ein Stück weit die
Zukunft wie sieht eigentlich der
Jugendschutz in mitterwasser aus
ja dann fangen wir einfach direkt mal an
warum eigentlich Jugendschutz was hat
sich sozusagen der Staat dabei gedacht
Ziel des Jugendmedienschutzes ist eine
möglichst unbeeinträchtigen
Entwicklungsmöglichkeit für Kinder und
Jugendliche zu erzielen das heißt Kinder
und Jugendliche sollen gesund es sollen
ein es sollen ein gesundes Aufwachsen
mit Medien ermöglicht werden und sie
sollen sich hin zu einer
eigenverantwortlichen Gemeinschaft
zwingen Persönlichkeit im Sinne des
gesetzlichen medienschutzes entwickeln
hintergrund ist der Gedanke dass
bestimmte Einflüsse oft aus der
Erwachsenenwelt dem Entwicklungsstand
von Kindern und Jugendlichen noch nicht
entsprechen und entsprechend auch noch
nicht so von ihnen verarbeitet werden
können
Jugendmedienschutz besitzt in
Deutschland sogar Verfassungsrang es ist
eine Schranke der Meinungsfreiheit nach
Artikel 5 des Grundgesetzes das heißt
das ist wirklich ein ganz ganz hohes Gut
in Deutschland und in dem Sinn ist der
gesetzliche Jugendmedienschutz auch
wirklich sehr
hochrangig in Deutschland
wie unterscheiden grundsätzlich drei
Arten von Jugendmedienschutz das eine
ist der strukturelle Jugendmedienschutz
also sprich wie können Gefahren und in
Beeinträchtigung grundsätzlich vermieten
werden schon in der Strukturen der
Anlage das zweite ist der gesetzliche
Jugendmedienschutz also was tut
eigentlich der Staat um Kinder und
Jugendliche zu schützen und das tritt
dass der erzieherische Jugendschutz also
wie kann man entsprechend auch Medien
bildungstechnisch vorbeugen um Kinder
und Jugendliche auch gut durch
entsprechende Begleitung oder Medien zu
begleiten
jetzt können wir uns mal angucken was
gibt es für Instrumente im Jugendschutz
wir haben einerseits diese
pädagogischen Instrumente also wirklich
so diese zwei Seiten der Medaille im
Jugendmedienschutz das eine sind die
Themen Schutz und Orientierung und das
andere ist die Befähigung und Teilhabe
und beim Schutz und der Orientierung
sehen wir zum Beispiel Instrumente wie
Altersfreigaben zum Beispiel der USK
oder auch im Filmbereich der FSK neu mit
dazu kommen auch entsprechend
Zusatzhinweise für Nutzerinnen und
Nutzer um entsprechenden Orientierung
bei Medienangeboten zu erhalten es gibt
weitere Mittel des gesetzlichen
Jugendschutzes das sind zum Beispiel
sendezeitgrenzen im Fernsehen die sind
heutzutage mit der Vielfalt an
Online-Angeboten natürlich nicht mehr
ganz so relevant aber hinzu tritt
hinzutreten weitere Mittel wie zum
Beispiel der technische
Jugendmedienschutz der natürlich im
Online-Bereich immer mehr an Bedeutung
gewinnt das sind zum Beispiel
altersverifikationsmaßnahmen der ein
oder andere kennt vielleicht die
Jugendschutz PIN bei Sky und hat sich
schon mal darüber geärgert auch das hört
man immer wieder oder eben auch die
ganzen parental control Systeme die
jetzt zum Beispiel auf den gängigen
Konsolen auch gibt zum Beispiel auf der
Xbox oder auf der Nintendo Switch und so
weiter und so fort
hinzugekommen ist jetzt mit dem neuen
Jugendschutzgesetz auch ein
regulierungsthema das entsprechend
anbietet dazu verpflichtet auch
Vorsorgemaßnahmen in ihren Angeboten zu
treffen das heißt dieser technische
Jugendschutz wurde jetzt auch gesetzlich
verankert
und auf der anderen Seite steht
natürlich ganz stark auch das Thema
Befähigung und Teilhabe nämlich die
Förderung von Medienkompetenz das
Mitnehmen von Kindern und Jugendlichen
durch medienpädagogische Projekte oder
auch Medienarbeit und natürlich auch der
Schutzgedanke Kinder und Jugendliche mit
einem Rüstzeug auszustatten dass sie
selbst befähigt werden sich zu schützen
bzw auch eine gewisse Resilienz bei der
Rezeption von Medien angeboten
entsprechend zu entwickeln
ja wie sieht der gesetzliche
Jugendmedienschutz jetzt eigentlich aus
es gibt verschiedene
regulierungsebenen im Jugendmedienschutz
wir haben hier drei Ebenen einerseits
die europäische Ebene wo zum Beispiel
Regulierungen wie der Digital Service
act jetzt ganz neu auch seit 2022
beschlossen verankert ist wo
entsprechend große Online Plattformen zu
bestimmten Vorsorgemaßnahme
Sicherungsmechanismen entsprechend
verpflichtet werden oder die audioselle
Mediendienste Richtlinie wir haben auf
der Bundesebene das Jugendschutzgesetzes
das tatsächlich die Verbreitung von
Medien angeboten in der Öffentlichkeit
regelt und bestimmte
abgabebeschränkungen auch beinhaltet und
wir haben auf der Länderebene den
Jugendmedien Staatsvertrag der den
Jugendschutz im Online-Bereich regelt
also nicht unter komplex die ganze
Materie und das Ganze spielt natürlich
auch ineinander wer spielt jetzt mit auf
Seiten auf Akteure ich kann nur so viel
sagen es ist ziemlich kompliziert
deswegen habe ich jetzt eine Folie
mitgebracht die hoffentlich ein bisschen
Licht ins Dunkel bringt
das eine wie gesagt das
Jugendschutzgesetz dass die klassischen
Altersfreigaben regelt das heißt die wir
auch von den Filmen kennen wie die FSK
Alterskennzeichen aber auch im Bereich
der Computer und Videospiele die USK wir
haben ganz neu jetzt gesetzlich
verankert auch eine
Kennzeichnungspflicht für Online
Spieleplattformen das heißt künftig ist
zu erwarten dass auch große
Spieleplattformen wie zum Beispiel Steam
oder auch andere entsprechend
Kennzeichen vorhalten müssen um Eltern
hier auch Orientierung zu bieten auf der
anderen Seite haben wir den Jugendmedien
Staatsvertrag eben entsprechend im
Nachhinein wirkt das heißt das
Jugendschutzgesetz wird immer vor
Markteintritt werden entsprechend
Medienangebote
beurteilt und im jugendlichen
Staatsvertrag kümmert sich die Medien
auf sich dann entsprechend um Verstöße
im Jugendschutz
hier habe ich mal so ein paar
aufsichtsinstitutionen Deutschland
aufgelistet an der
Altersfreigabe sind zum Beispiel die
Obersten Landesjugendbehörden beteiligt
die heutige bundeszentrale für Kinder
und Jugendmedienschutz frühere
Bundesprüfstelle für jugendgefährte
Medien ist die zuständige Behörde die
auch entsprechend Medien in Deutschland
initiieren kann was heißt Indizierung da
komme ich später noch dazu aber im
Endeffekt dürfen Medien dann
entsprechend nur noch an Erwachsene
verkauft werden also unter dem
Ladentisch wie es so schön heißt oder
auch entsprechend dann nicht mehr
beworben werden die anderen Seite im
Online-Bereich ist die Funktion der
Aufsicht entsprechend Jugendschutz
Verstöße zu ahnten und dann mit
Bußgeldern und Aufsichtsverfahren an die
Anbieter heranzutreten
eine Besonderheit im jugendschutz ist
tatsächlich dass der gesetzliche
Jugendschutz auf das System der
regulierten Selbstregulierung aufbaut
das haben wir auch in Deutschland sonst
nicht so häufig das heißt Staat und
Wirtschaft arbeiten gemeinsam an diesen
wichtigen Thema
Jugendmedienschutz ne also was sozusagen
auch eine sehr hohe gesellschaftliche
Relevanz beinhaltet aber es gibt auf der
einen Seite Institutionen wie die
Unterhaltungssoftware Selbstkontrolle
aber auch die freiwillige
Selbstkontrolle der Filmwirtschaft die
FSK oder für den Fernsehbereich die FSF
ähm bis hin zu FSM die dann alle tiktoks
und snapchat dieser Welt vereint
ja wie sieht jetzt konkret der
Jugendschutz bei Games aus wir haben in
Deutschland besonders verbindliche
Regeln auch im weltweiten Vergleich wir
sind hier wirklich Vorreiter was die
Regelungsmaterie anbelangt der die
Prüfung von Spielen für den Handel und
die Öffentlichkeit ist entsprechend
verbindlich das heißt wenn Anbieter ihr
Spiel in Deutschland an Minderjährige
verkaufen wollen dann brauchen Sie
entsprechenden usk-kennzeichen dass eben
auch mit staatlicher Beteiligung
zustande kommt
ich habe es schon erwähnt der Staat hat
natürlich jetzt auch erkannt naja da
sind ja auch ziemlich viele Angebote die
rein Online-Angeboten werden auch da
wollen wir Orientierung fördern das
heißt wir haben mit der Novelle des
Jugendschutzgesetzes seit 2021 nun auch
eine Kennzeichnungspflicht für große
online Spieleplattformen wie die zu
einem Kennzeichen kommen ist dann aber
ein Stück weit ein Stück weit flexibler
geregelt als das jetzt aktuell im
triggermedienmarkt der Fall ist das
heißt da sind auch automatisierte
Bewertungssysteme die entsprechende
Wirtschaft auch schon seit zehn Jahren
entwickelt hat möglich
ja und dann kommen wir auch gleich mal
dazu was eigentlich die
Unterhaltungssoftware Selbstkontrolle
macht wir sind die gesetzlich anerkannte
selbst Kontrolleinrichtung in
Deutschland und wir sind zuständig für
die Prüfung von digitalen Spielen unser
Gesellschafter ist die Industrie das
heißt der Game der Verband der deutschen
Gamesbranche ganz wichtig aber die
Industrie darf nicht beteiligt sein
anderen altersfreigabeverfahren sondern
ist nur das wirtschaftliche Risiko der
USK
die USK wird auch beraten von einem
Plural aufgestellten Beirat da sind zum
Beispiel gesellschaftliche Institutionen
drinnen wie die Kirchen aber auch wie
verschiedene Behörden zum Beispiels
Bundesfamilienministerium oder
Akteurinnen und Akteure der Kinder und
Jugendhilfe die entsprechend dann die
Kriterien der Alterskennzeichnung
festlegen
hier noch ein paar Zahlen wer ist
eigentlich bei der USK für die
Altersfreigaben dann zuständig wir haben
einen Pool an rund 50 unabhängige
Jugendschutz Sachverständigen die aus
dem Bereich der Kinder- und Jugendhilfe
kommen aber auch aus dem Bereich
Medienpädagogik also sprich direkt mit
Kindern und Jugendlichen zu tun haben um
wirklich auch einschätzen zu können
welche Inhalte wirken wie auf Kinder und
Jugendliche
darüber hinaus gibt es zwei ständige
Vertreter der Obersten
Landesjugendbehörden bei der USK die
dann entsprechend den Verwaltungsakt
also wirklich ein behördlichen
sozusagen Verwaltungsakt dann für die
Altersfreigabe erstellen
seit der Gründung im Jahr 1994 haben wir
rund 50.000 Verfahren zur gesetzlichen
Altersfreigabe durchgeführt das scheint
jetzt im Vergleich zu den vielen
Online-Angeboten wenig wirken aber auch
da haben wir eine Lösung entwickelt und
vergeben rund 2,5 Millionen altes
Kennzeichen über ein automatisiertes
Bewertungssystem für Spieleplattform im
Jahr
des Weiteren haben wir aktuell 50 aktive
Mitglieder aus der Gamesbranche die sich
der USK angeschlossen haben und
dauerhaft im Jugendschutz kooperieren
das reicht von eSports Anbietern bis
über den großen Publisher kleinere in
die Unternehmen also die Bandbreite ist
da sehr groß
jetzt möchte ich mal ein bisschen
erläutern wie denn eigentlich so ein
Alterskennzeichen entsteht und wer
darüber entscheidet ich habe es schon
erzählt vor Release eines Titels
vorveröffentlichung kommt ein Spiel bei
der USK an der Titel wird entsprechend
gesichtet von sichterinnen und Sichtern
die auch unabhängig sein müssen und
entsprechend durchgespielt natürlich
haben wir vom Entwickler auch immer
wieder Hilfestellungen wie zum Beispiel
ja auch ein paar ja
entsprechendes Material und so weiter
und so fort wichtig ist aber und das ist
auch einzigartig im Vergleich zu anderen
Rating Institutionen weltweit dass die
USA wirklich tatsächlich spielt
danach wird dieses Spiel in einer in
einem prüfgremium präsentiert und dann
anhand der Leitkriterien der USK zu
altersbewertung diskutiert ein Gremium
besteht im aus 4
jugendschutz-fachverständigen und einer
ständigen Vertretung der Oberlandes
Jugendbehörden die entsprechenden
Vorsatz hat so eine kann natürlich von
Spiel zu Spiel unterschiedlich sein also
so eine Präsentation des Titels je
nachdem wie umfangreich ist der ist kann
schon mal von bis zu einer Stunde dauern
ein bis zwei Stunden kann man damit
schon rechnen die Herausforderung ist
natürlich anders als beim Film
entsprechend wirklich das Spiel in Gänze
und vor allem darzustellen um was es
eigentlich geht wie sozusagen das
Gameplay sich aufbaut was der Spieler
oder die Spielerin entsprechend im Spiel
erwartet und natürlich auch wo sie die
Jugendschutz relevante Spitzen drin die
die Gremien erkennen müssen und dann
entsprechend beurteilen müssen
Ergebnis ist dann entsprechend die
Altersfreigabe die wirklich als
behördlicher Verwaltungsakt dann an dem
Anbieter ergeht und ihm dann sozusagen
auch bescheinigt dieses Spiel
entsprechend in Deutschland verbreiten
zu können neu dabei sind auch Themen wie
Zusatzhinweise das heißt künftig wird
die USK hier auch textliche Hinweise die
Auskunft zur zu den Gründen der
Altersfreigabe und eventuellen
nutzungsrisiken sozusagen mit mit
dazugeben
wichtig für Anbieter ist ein
usk-kennzeichen schützt vor einer
Indizierung das heißt er hält ein
Anbieter in der USK 18 ist er geschützt
davor von der Bundeszentrale für Kinder
und Jugendschutz indiziert zu werden
ja und dann waren da die so vielen Apps
was machen wir eigentlich damit und ich
habe bisschen schon was vorweggenommen
das ist natürlich eine sehr große
Herausforderung gewesen wie man
entsprechend mit so vielen Angeboten im
Online-Bereich umgeht wir haben das
gegen uns schon vor zehn Jahren auf den
Weg gemacht mit anderen Rating
Institutionen weltweit zum Beispiel auch
die mit der europäischen
Alterskennzeichnung PG aber auch den
Amerikanern und den Brasilianern
entsprechendes System zu gründen die
international age Rating kurdischen wo
sozusagen in Verbund zusammen ein System
entwickelt haben dass wir Spiele
Plattformen bereitstellen um
Alterskennzeichen zu generieren wie
funktioniert das ganze nicht mehr der
Entwickler selbst reicht sein Spiel
entsprechend bei der USK oder eine
anderen Situation ein sondern der als
sozusagen ein Fragebogen er das eintritt
die Eintrittskarte ist um auf einer
Spieleplattform verbreiten zu können das
heißt der Spieleentwickler wird erstmal
gefragt was genau bietest du an und wird
dann sozusagen durch einen Fragebogen
geleitet mit allen möglichen
Jugendschutz relevanten Fragen die
werden dann entsprechend anhand der
regionalen Bewertungskriterien
ausgewertet so dass dann egal ob man
jetzt in den USA sitzt oder in
Deutschland der Nutzer die Nutzerin
entsprechend das Kennzeichen das
regional verwendet wird auch ja zu
Gesicht bekommt
mittlerweile sind sehr sehr viele große
Spieleplattform mit dabei wir haben die
Xbox Google Play Store dem PlayStation
Store Nintendo eShop Oculus und viele
weitere sind in der Pipeline
ja soviel erstmal zur
Alterskennzeichnung wie der Prozess
funktioniert jetzt möchte ich mal ein
bisschen näher eingehen auf die
Leitkriterien also wie entsprechend
Computer und Videospiele eigentlich
eingeordnet werden grundsätzlich
vorweggenommen die USK hat einen sehr
positiven
Blickwinkel aufspiele das heißt das ist
auch notwendig natürlich weil
mittlerweile 91% der 12 bis 19-Jährigen
digitale Spiele spielen das heißt Games
sind in der Lebensrealität von Kindern
und Jugendlichen angekommen und das kann
man sozusagen auch nicht
ignorieren da hat sich auch in den
letzten Jahren sehr sehr viel am Image
von Games auch gesellschaftlich getan
grundsätzlich ist es so dass die USK
Teilhabe ermöglicht das heißt die USK
verbietet keine Spiele sondern sie gibt
sie entsprechend frei dass Kinder und
Jugendliche auch unbeschwert teilhaben
können
ja und Spiele können natürlich so viel
sein von der Unterhaltung angefangen und
Unterhaltung ist nach wie vor natürlich
das was Spiele können müssen sie müssen
Spaß machen das ist ihr Zweck insofern
auch das ist ein Aspekt der in unseren
Leitkriterien verankert ist sie können
auch Kunst sein sie können einen
kritischen Blick auf
gesellschaftsschulen wir sehen das sind
beispielsweise in ganz vielen in die
Games die sich mit gesellschaftlich
relevanten Themen auseinandersetzen wie
zum Beispiel Umwelt oder aber auch ähm
ja Bildungsaspekte Demokratie Demokratie
und so weiter und so fort und sie können
natürlich auch Lerninhalte sein das
heißt immer mehr wird sozusagen auch das
Potential von Games im Schulunterricht
erkannt
worauf basieren die Bewertungskriterien
der USK was haben wir uns da angeschaut
natürlich Gesetze und rechtliche
Grundlagen als Ausgangsbasis darüber
hinaus unsere Grundsätze und die
Spruchpraxis von mehr als 52.000
Verfahren Erkenntnisse aus Wissenschaft
und Medienforschung sind natürlich eine
ganz relevante Quelle und
gesellschaftliche Werte und Normen
ein No-Go jedoch sind Geschmacksurteile
oder tagespolitische Anschauungen das
ist explizit auch in unserem like
Kriterien ausgeschlossen im Vordergrund
steht wirklich immer die
wirkungsannahme die entsprechenden
Computer und Videospiele bei
Jugendlichen entfalten das heißt
Geschmacksurteile ob ich jetzt das ähm
Spielkonzept irgendwie schön finde oder
ob ich die Grafik
geeignet finde das sind alles Aspekte
die keine Rolle spielen darüber hinaus
sind die USK Kennzeichen keine
pädagogischen Empfehlungen sondern sagen
immer nur etwas aus über das
beeinträchtigungspotenzial auch dass es
ganz wichtig
ja und wie blickt die USK jetzt
eigentlich auf ein Computerspiel ich
habe uns da jetzt mal einen kleinen
Auszug mitgebracht aus unseren
Leitkriterien digitale Spiele sind in
erster Linie interaktiver
Unterhaltungsangebote oder der
Erlebnisangebote also die Interaktivität
steht natürlich ganz stark im
Vordergrund dass es auch schon was was
ich erzählt habe sie sollen unterhalten
also auch Games dürfen unterhalten auch
das ganz wichtig und sie folgen
regelverabredungen gemäß der genre-typik
und Erfolgen entsprechenden
Handlungsaufforderung oder enthalten
auch spezifische wettbewerbs- und
belohnungsmechanismen das ist der
sozusagen Satz aus den Leitkriterien wie
ein digitales Spiel bei uns definiert
wird
ja werden jetzt Games anders bewertet
als Filme ja und nein natürlich spielt
die die Spezifikation das Mediums auch
eine ganz ganz große Rolle die auch im
Hinblick auf die Jugendschutz Relevanz
berücksichtigt werden muss wir haben
natürlich mit
Computerspielen den Aspekt dass die
wesentlich immersiver sein können als
beispielsweise ein Film ich bin selber
der Handelnde oder die handelnde
Akteurin insofern ist natürlich das
Thema Interaktivität und
selbstwirksamkeitserleben ein ganz ganz
wichtiger Unterschied zum Beispiel zum
Film
wie sieht jetzt eigentlich die
wirkungsvermutung aus was berührt
berücksichtigen Rahmen der
Beeinträchtigung wir gucken uns immer
die Gesamtwirkung des Spiels an
natürlich können auch Einzelaspekte hin
zur beeinträchtnis beeinträchtigen
Potenzial entsprechend berühren
gleichzeitig ist aber immer wichtig das
Spiel in seinem in seiner Gesamtheit zu
beurteilen das heißt ich kann natürlich
mal schauen was sind die einzelnen
Gewaltspitzen aber am Ende muss ich
immer gucken was überträgt sich an den
Nutzer oder den NutzerInnen und wie ist
das gesamte Spielangebot einzubetten und
wie wirkt das gesamte Spielangebot
ich habe jetzt mal so ein paar Aspekte
mitgebracht die entsprechend die
Wirkmacht von denen eben vermutet wird
dass eine Wirkmacht ausgeht wir schauen
uns in erster Linie das Gameplay aus
also wie ist die spielverabredung wie
ist sozusagen die Spielmechanik
ausgebaut was ist eigentlich der ist das
Ziel des Spiels das Thema Atmosphäre
spielt eine große Rolle wenn man die
Jugendschutz Relevanz beurteilt also wie
düster ist das Spiel es ist locker ist
es heiter es ist eher schwer das sind
sozusagen auch natürlich Themen was
überträgt sich an Kinder und Jugendliche
wo können sie sich leichte distanzieren
das Thema jugendaffinität spielt eine
Rolle also sprich wie sehr können sich
Kinder und Jugendliche auch mit dem
Angebot ja identifizieren können Sie
sich dann ausreichend distanzieren und
wie stark wirkt das sozusagen auch in
ihre Lebenswelt hinein wir haben Themen
Glaubwürdigkeit natürlich auch Aspekte
wie Gewalt Darstellungen die nach wie
vor sehr im Vordergrund stehen auch das
Krieg ist insbesondere in Deutschland
ein ganz wichtiges Kriterium wenn es um
die Jugendschutz Relevanz geht aber
natürlich auch immer in Verbindung mit
wie realistisch sind die Darstellungen
wie stark können sich Kinder und
Jugendliche davon distanzieren ist das
ganze schon gelernt oder es entsprechend
sozusagen hier weniger geht
distanzierungsmöglichkeit da weil es
einfach sehr stark an der Lebenswelt von
Kindern Jugendlichen aufgehängt ist wir
haben immer wieder die Diskussionen über
zombie shooter und wie ist eigentlich
sozusagen der Zombie wahrgenommen
mittlerweile würde ich sagen der Zombie
ist auch in der Lebenswelt von Kindern
Jugendlichen angekommen insofern ist es
natürlich auch was wo man sieht dass
sich die Spruchpraxis entwickelt
gleichwohl es ist Thema
Menschenähnlichkeit und vor allem Gewalt
gegen menschenähnliche Gegner immer noch
ein ganz ganz wichtiges Kriterium wenn
es darum geht welche ja welche Spiele
entsprechend auch für eine jüngere
freigegeben werden können
das Thema Angst und Bedrohung ist ein
ganz wichtiger Aspekt relativ neu
besonders hervorgehoben wurde jetzt auch
das Thema Glücksspiel wo entsprechend
auch Themen wie zum Beispiel Förderung
von einem positiven von einer positiven
Einstellung zu echten Glücksspiel in die
Bewertung einfließt
sexuelle sexuelle Darstellungen wird
entsprechend auch mit aufgenommen wie
wir Sexualität oder sexuelle Beziehungen
zwischen Menschen bewertet was schwingt
damit wie sind die Darstellung und so
weiter und so fort
mit ein Hauptgrund für unsere 6 oder 12
war Freigaben ist auch der
Handlungsdruck ins spielen also
Handlungsdruck spielte ganz große Rolle
vor allem zwischen den Altersfreigaben
zwischen 0 und 6 das heißt wie stark
bringt mich das Spiel dazu zu agieren
kann ich einmal durchschnaufen kann ich
irgendwie Pausen machen
insofern es Handlungsdruck wirklich auch
ein ganz wichtiger Aspekt
Identifikationspotenzial habe ich schon
genannt aber auch andere Themen wie
Drogen wie ist der rauchende Pirat zu
bewerten und wie bettelt sich der ganze
ins ganze Spiel mit ein es ist zynisch
ist es sarkastisch können sich Kinder
davon distanzieren oder wird sogar
Drogenhandel irgendwie glorifiziert oder
ähnliches
Sprache auch ein ganz weites Feld wie
derb ist die Sprache sind einzelne
Schimpfwörter oder geht es dann wirklich
auch bis hin zu zur Vulgärsprache
hier mal ein kleiner Überblick wie das
sich das so in den Altersfreigaben
bewegt wir haben beispielsweise im
Bereich der nullerfreigaben wirklich die
ganz klassischen Familien oder
Sportspiele wo entsprechend wieder
Gewalt noch sonstige beeinträchtige
Inhalte zu finden sind dann sind wir bei
Sechser Inhalten die schon ein bisschen
stärker in Handlungsdruck zum Beispiel
haben wir denn können dann zum Beispiel
ein Jump and runs denken wo ich
irgendwie schnell doch eine Welt mich
bewege und auch ganz schnell
entsprechend Aktionen tätigen muss da
finden wir sowas wie angedeutet Gewalt
oder Comic Gewalt recht häufig wir haben
dann die 12er Freigaben wo es dann schon
ein bisschen realistische wird wenn es
um Gewalt Darstellung geht wie aber
immer noch ein sehr starken Fantasy
Setting unterwegs sind sodass dann noch
ausreichend distanzierungspotenzial
möglich ist
bei den 16er Freigaben wird es dann
schon deutlich kampfbetonter wir denken
zum Beispiel eine Sessions Creed aber
auch da haben wir immer noch ganz starke
Möglichkeit entsprechend die Gewalt
einzuordnen indem wir Gewalt darstellen
unrealistisch sind bzw sich sehr stark
auch von der eigenen Lebenswelt
entfernen weil sie zum Beispiel einen
unrealistischen Setting spielen und dann
sind wir im Bereich der 18er
Freigaben wo dann die Gewalt schon
entsprechend drastisch und wuchtig ist
wo die gewalttasche betont wird und auch
da sehen wir immer noch mal eine
Schwelle zu Indizierung also die USK
Gremien müssen entsprechend auch immer
die indizierungskriterien der
Bundeszentrale für Kinder und
medienschutz berücksichtigen das heißt
immer auch in ihren Freigaben
berücksichtigen ob entsprechend ein
Spiel Potenzial hat um auf dem Index zu
landen
ja hier habe ich mal so ein kleine
Übersicht mitgebracht welche Spiele das
so sind und das mal so ein bisschen zu
mit dem Beispiel zu unterlegen wir sehen
im Urlaub Bereich zum Beispiel schöne
Evergreens von Nintendo wie zum Beispiel
Animal Crossing gesehen im Sechser
Bereich ein klassisches Jump and Run mit
Super Mario wir sehen ein schönes Wunder
die wunderschöne Horizon Reihe
entsprechend bei den 12er Freigaben und
glscrolls bei einer 16 auch da sehr
stark im Mittelalter Setting angesiedelt
bis hin zu einem Call of Duty wo wir
dann schon ganz stark in kriegssetting
drin sind dass ich mit der realen Welt
schon sehr sehr stark gekoppelt
jetzt möchte ich meinen kleinen Exkurs
noch werfen auf das Thema Indizierung
ich habe es schon erwähnt Antragsteller
die entsprechend auch ein
Alterskennzeichen bei der USK bekommen
sind grundsätzlich von der Indizierung
geschützt das heißt sie sind nicht mehr
sie laufen nicht mehr Gefahr
entsprechend ein paar
breitungsverbot entsprechend auferlegt
zu bekommen die bzkj früher bjm wird auf
Antrag tätig und ist eben für die
Indizierungen in Deutschland zuständig
Hintergrund ist immer der Gedanke dass
entsprechend Medien auch Jugend
gefährden wirken können das heißt
entsprechend Kinder und Jugendliche in
ihrer Entwicklung zu einer
gemeinschaftsfähigen Persönlichkeit
gefährdet werden können da sind wir dann
beispielsweise bei Themen wie Gewalt
Verherrlichung der selbstzweckhaften
Gewalt also wenn Gewalt ausgeübt wird
ohne jeglichen Sinn sage ich jetzt mal
wenn man jetzt irgendwie Gegner Figuren
kämpft da sind wir zum Beispiel bei
Themen wie post mortem Zerstückelung die
dann entsprechend schön noch mal in alle
Einzelteile erfolgen kann ohne dass da
irgendwie Gameplay technisch auch
irgendwie noch ein Sinn dahinter steht
und so weiter
natürlich auch Themen die strafrechtlich
relevant sind oder sein können spielen
eine Rolle wie Verherrlichung des
Nationalsozialismus aber auch andere
Themen wie Diskriminierung von
Menschengruppen Verherrlichung von
Drogenkonsum und so weiter
hier habe ich mal ein paar Beispiele
mitgebracht um auch schon mal zu zeigen
wie sich die Spruchpraxis deine letzten
Jahren verändert hat ich habe gehört ihr
habt heute schon über das Spiel
Wolfenstein 3D geredet da habe ich auch
noch mal was mitgebracht das war ja
lange beschlagnahmt und auch indiziert
von der Bundesprüfstelle für
jugendgefährde Medien damals
mittlerweile heute mit einem Kennzeichen
versehen wir sehen da die sehr
unrealistische Grafik und auch immer die
Themen was überträgt sich da eigentlich
an Kinder und Jugendliche die im
Vordergrund steht wir haben das Spiel
River Raid beispielsweise wo auch noch
davon ausgegangen werden wurde damals
1984 das erste initierte Spiel wo damals
davon ausgegangen worden ist dass Kinder
und Jugendliche die dieses Spiel spielen
entsprechend auch ja dass da eben
entsprechend Gewalt verharmlost wird
wenn ich da entsprechend die Schiffe und
so weiter irgendwie abschießen
und wir haben die dubenreihe die auch
lange indiziert war ich glaube 1993 muss
das gewesen sein vielleicht auch nagelt
mich jetzt nicht ganz fest auf jeden
Fall mittlerweile auch nicht mehr
indiziert aufgrund dessen dass die
spielverabredung klar ist dass die
Gewaltdarstellung unrealistisch ist und
das entsprechend auch nicht mehr davon
ausgegangen wird dass sich da auf
Spielerinnen und Spieler die diese Spiel
spielen etwas überträgt
natürlich wandelt sich auch die
Spruchpraxis der USK im Wandel der Zeit
wichtig für uns sind natürlich auch
immer die Entscheidungen der
Spruchpraxis der Bundeszentrale für
Kinder und Jugendmedienschutz die
entsprechen dann auch immer sozusagen in
die Karte dafür ist wenn Spielen nicht
mehr auf dem Index steht dass dann steht
eigentlich der Freigabe durch die USA
nichts mehr liege gleichzeitig natürlich
auch die steigenden wachsenden
Medienerfahrung von Kindern Jugendlichen
Medien haben sich verändert viele sind
viel mehr im Mittelpunkt der
Lebensrealität von Kindern und
Jugendlichen Kinder und Jugendliche
haben jetzt mittlerweile auch eine ganz
andere Art und Weise mit Medien
umzugehen und natürlich auch immer das
was man sozusagen auch schon gewohnt ist
an Grafik und so weiter und so fort
spielt da eine Rolle
Erkenntnisse aus Wissenschaft und
Forschung wir hatten lange Zeit in
Deutschland die sogenannte
killer-spiel-debatte aus der damals auch
2003 des Jugendschutzgesetz erwachsen
ist wo lange angenommen wurde oder von
manchen angenommen wurde dass sich die
Gewalt in Spielen direkt auf
Spielerinnen und Spieler überträgt diese
Korrelation diese unmittelbare die
konnte niemals wissenschaftlich belegt
werden und mittlerweile sind wir auch
nicht mehr in diesen Diskussionen
sondern ist eigentlich relativ klar dass
da immer mehr Faktoren dazu gehören als
nur der reine Medienkonsum
und natürlich auch noch Themen wie die
Änderung der Rechtsauffassung oder aber
auch der rechtliche Grundlagen ganz
grundsätzlich da hat sie jetzt in der
letzten Zeit auch noch mal eine
Veränderung ergeben die ich auch heute
noch mal kurz skizzieren möchte
ja ich habe schon erwähnt Spruchpraxis
ist ein ganz ganz wichtiger Faktor der
Bundeszentrale für medienschutz also der
Behörde die initiieren kann mittlerweile
hat die doom-reihe auch ja ziemlich
sicher eigentlich in USA 18 Kennzeichen
auch Mortal Kombat sind wir mittlerweile
bei einer 18 die Gewaltdarstellung
können für den ein oder anderen
natürlich auch noch drastisch sein also
drastische gewalttaschen sind damit drin
aber der Inhalt wird nicht mehr als
jugendgefährdend angesehen weil eben
entsprechend die Gewalt Darstellungen
auch
unrealistisch sind weiß nicht um den
selbstweghaften ähm ja Aspekt der Gewalt
geht sondern weil entsprechend auch
Computer und Videospiele schon in der
Lebensrealität angekommen sind
ein weiteres Thema das auch ein Stück
weit auf diese steigenden
Medienerfahrung abzielt vielleicht hat
der ein oder andere mitbekommen Fortnite
mit eines der beliebtesten Spiele bei
Kindern Jugendlichen hat entsprechend
auch eine USK 12 Freigabe bekommen das
war ein Stück weit wirklich ein großer
Wandel in der Spruchpraxis weil zuvor
vor allem Shooter Spiele kategorisch
muss man schon fast sagen beinahe 16
eingeordnet waren Fortnite war natürlich
ein Spiel was plötzlich ganz anders war
Fortnite hatte eine super
comic-hafte Grafik es standen neben der
sage ich mal Shooter neben dem Spiel
neben dem Spiel ist weg entsprechend
auch durch abschießen der Gegner dann
der das Team zu sein das am Ende noch
steht entsprechend auch noch andere
Themen im Vordergrund lustige Tänze in
der richtige Kultur die sich um Fortnite
rum bewegt hat aber natürlich auch das
Teamplay was vor allem auch dann die
Gremien dazu gebracht hat dieses Spiel
noch mal anders
einzuordnen und entsprechend auch zu
sehen dass das nicht die Wirkmacht
entfaltet oder für unter zwölfjährige
nicht mehr
entwicklungsbeeinträchtigend anzusehen
ist
ein Beispiel das heute ja auch schon
Erwähnung fanden dass das Thema
Hakenkreuze in Computerspielen da hat
sich auch einiges getan in den letzten
Jahren seit 2018 oder sagen wir mal so
bis 2018 durften Spiele die Kennzeichen
die verfassungswidder Organisation also
sprich Hakenkreuze enthalten haben
überhaupt nicht bei der USK eingereicht
werden warum da wurde auch immer noch
mal eine Ungleichbehandlung zwischen dem
Medium Games und dem Medium Film
entsprechend deutlich weil entsprechend
der die Ausnahme warum Hakenkreuze unter
Umständen in Deutschland gezeigt und
erlaubt werden dürfen nicht an Games
angewandt wurden weil Games nicht als
Kunst
klassifiziert wurden sind sondern
entsprechend sozusagen von diesem Verbot
immer noch umfasst waren was hat sich
dann geändert 2018 hat eine Änderung der
Obersten Landesjugendbehörden gegeben
der rechtsauf dahingegen geändert haben
dass die sozial adäquanzklausel auch bei
Spielen angewendet werden kann
hintergrund war der das sogar zur
Bundestagswahl damals 2017 Spiel
entwickelt worden ist wo eine bestimmte
Partei und ihr Protagonist als
Hakenkreuz dargestellt worden ist der
entsprechend dann auch von Angela Merkel
und anderen bekämpft werden musste und
insofern war das dann sozusagen
politisch sogar eingesetzt und dann
wurde es von der Staatsanwaltschaft auch
nicht beschlagnahmt und das war dann
sozusagen der Auslöser dafür für die
oberste Landesjugendbehörden ihre
Rechtsauffassung zu ändern und zu sagen
okay wir müssen im Einzelfall prüfen
können ob ein Spiel das Kennzeichen
verfassungswegeorganisation enthält
nicht doch auch sozial artegrad sein
kann
zwei ganz prominente Beispiele sind zum
Beispiel für the darkest of times ein
Spiel des sämtliche Preise gewonnen hat
da geht es darum entsprechend auch im
nationalsozialistischen Regime ein eine
Widerstandsgruppe aufzubauen um dagegen
anzukämpfen natürlich hat dieses Spiel
auch in der entsprechende Visualisierung
beinhaltet wo auch Hakenkreuze gezeigt
werden konnten das war das erste Spiel
dass das von der USK eine Freigabe ab 18
Jahren nicht ab 18 Jahren sondern ab 12
Jahren dann entsprechend bekommen hat
andere Spiele wie zum Beispiel
Wolfenstein die Wolfenstein Reihe wurden
extra für den deutschen Markt
entsprechend verändert so dass auch bei
Kritikern immer wieder laut wurde naja
das könnte ja schon fast eine
Verharmlosung des Nationalsozialismus
sein wenn man entsprechend alles was mit
dem Nationalsozialismus zu tun hat in
solchen Spielen kategorisch entsprechend
ausschließt oder so
verändert und fast schon verharmlos ist
das entsprechende wirkliche Spielinhalt
gar nicht mehr zu Geltung kommt auch
diese Spiele wurden im Einzelfall von
der USK geprüft und entsprechend eine
jugendgefährdende Wirkung konnte hier
nicht festgestellt werden so dass die
auch mittlerweile mit einer USK 18
gekennzeichnet sind
ein weiteres Thema das gerade auch in
der letzten Zeit bei Computerspielen
immer wieder diskutiert wird ist das
Thema Glücksspiel oder vielmehr
simuliertes Glücksspiel ohne
echtgeldausschüttung das wurde 2020 als
eigener Aspekt der Wirkmacht in den USK
Leitkriterien verankert hintergrund war
dass sich die Medien an Landschaft auch
entsprechend verändert hat und immer
mehr Apps und Games of dem Markt
erschienen sind die entsprechendes
Glücksspiel simulieren
simuliert das Glücksspiel das ist ein
ganz wichtiges Kriterien in dem Sinn
müssen eben entsprechend auch ein
zentraler Aspekt der Spielmechanik sein
um entsprechend Jugendschutz relevant zu
werden und auch ein wichtiges Kriterien
die positive Einstellung gegenüber
echten Glücksspiel also mit
echtgeldausschüttung dann entsprechend
zu fördern echtes Glücksspiel ist in
Deutschland auch für Minderjährige
verboten
hier habe ich ein Beispiel mitgebracht
coin Master war auch in den Medien immer
wieder ein Beispiel dass man aufgebracht
wurde eine App die entsprechend immer
wieder mit entsprechenden ja simulierten
Glücksspiel Elementen gespielt hat und
bei Anführungszeichen und dann auch auf
die 16 hoch gerutscht ist in der
Jugendschutz Relevanz
ja wie sieht die Zukunft aus und vor
allem die Spruchpraxis die uns jetzt in
den nächsten Jahren erwartet wir haben
ein neues Jugendschutzgesetz seit 2021
das entsprechend auch ganz neue Aspekte
bei Computer und Videospielen jetzt ins
Auge fasst und zwar den Schutz der
persönliche Integrität das ist für die
USK die größte Änderung seit bestehen
weil auch Elemente in Spielen die
außerhalb des medieninhalts
stattfinden auch in den Blickpunkt der
Bewertung Rücken der Gesetzgeber will
vor allem Risiken wie Cyber creaming
Cybermobbing aber auch Kosten riesigen
ungewollten Ausgaben aber auch sowas wie
eine Förderung des exzessiven
Nutzungsverhalten
entgegenwirken und entsprechend auch
diese Aspekte mit in der Bewertung oder
mit im Prüfprozess berücksichtigt werden
da geht's zum Beispiel auch zum Themen
wie Selbstregulierung also welche
Elemente setzen viel ein um gezielt
meine Selbstregulierung auch oder die
Selbstregierung von Kinder und
Jugendlichen natürlich entsprechend auch
zu beeinflussen vielleicht negativ zu
beeinflussen zum Beispiel durch
Bestrafungen im Spiel wenn ich nicht
spiele was sozusagen auch entsprechend
die persönlichen getät von Kindern
Jugendlichen angreifen könnte aber auch
Themen wie kommerzial kommerzielle
Autonomie also zum Beispiel wie
Kaufdruck ist im Spiel enthalten gibt es
sozusagen Vorsorgemaßnahmen des
Anbieters um entsprechend Risiken
entgegenzuwirken das heißt kann ich bei
Käufen Limit setzen ist eine Transparenz
da wie hoch die Ausgaben im Spiel sein
werden all diese Themen werden uns in
Zukunft beschäftigen
und das ist wirklich revolutionär es ist
ein Stück weit ein Paradigmenwechsel im
Schutzgedanken bis jetzt haben wir uns
immer den Medieninhalt angeschaut der
nicht fluktuativ ist der erstmal da ist
und jetzt müssen sozusagen alle Umstände
wie zum Beispiel auch so ein Chat
berücksichtigt werden die ja doch sehr
fluktuativ sind und wo entsprechend
unsere Gremien jetzt auch erstmal so
eine Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit für ein
Risiko bemessen müssen das heißt es geht
viel mehr um Risiko Einschätzungen als
entsprechend wirklich um ja eine
Beurteilung des medieninhalts und wir
haben natürlich auch neue Instrumente
hinzubekommen wir haben einerseits ich
nenne es mal das verbotsinstrument
nämlich die Alterskennzeichen die immer
mehr sage ich meine letzten Jahren vom
Verbot hin also schutzaspekt hin zu
Orientierung gewandert sind weil
natürlich gerade mit der sage ich mal
wenigen Kontrolle im Online-Bereich ihr
die Orientierungsfunktion hochgerutscht
anstatt der Schutzfunktion aber wir
haben eben entsprechend neue Faktoren
mit dabei hier links unten sieht man
entsprechend auch Zusatzhinweise die
künftig in Spielen Beispielen auftauchen
werden jetzt auch schon sind zum
Beispiel im Rahmen der
online-spieleplattform ist es auch schon
weit verbreitetes Modell entsprechend
mit Deskriptoren mit Zusatz Hinweisen zu
arbeiten um entsprechend auch
potenzielle Risiken auszuweisen Eltern
zu sensibilisieren wenn Eltern wissen
dass hier ein Chat mit enthalten ist
können Sie entsprechend auch die
Voreinstellungen so wählen dass Kinder
und Jugendliche a entweder den Chat
entsprechend nicht nutzen dürfen oder B
entsprechende Einstellung getroffen
werden das an chatten nur mit Freunden
oder Bekannten Personen möglich ist und
natürlich auch das dritte Thema nämlich
sicherer Teilhabe und Befähigung durch
Vorsorgemaßnahmen das Anbieters das
heißt der Anbieter muss entsprechende
Vorsorgemaßnahmen bereithalten im Spiel
wie zum Beispiel meldemöglichkeiten
papierfunktionen um entsprechend auch da
Risiken für Kinder und Jugendliche
abzufedern es wird sehr spannend wie das
in der Spruchpraxis ausgehen wird ist
noch ein Stück weit steht noch ein Stück
weit in den Sternen das werden wir auch
in den nächsten kommenden Jahren sehen
hier gibt es noch sehr sehr wenig
Spruchpraxis bis keine insofern werden
das wirklich dann auch Leitplanken
Entscheidungen werden
das habe ich schon gezeigt wichtig wie
gesagt neu zu den altersfragen mit dazu
kommen wird dass die wesentlichen Gründe
für die Altersfreigabe ausgewiesen
werden das heißt NutzerInnen nutzt auf
einen Blick erkennen was denn jetzt so
Altersfreigabe geführt hat zum Beispiel
bei USK 6 die Schreckmomente oder bei
der zwölf die kriegsthematik bis hin zur
drastischen Gewalt und ähnliches
ja und jetzt vielleicht mal ganz kurz
über das Mieter worst da könnte ich
glaube ich jetzt einen eigenen Vortrag
halten deswegen habe ich jetzt einfach
mal versucht in einer slide mal kurz das
Thema Jugendschutz und Mieter worse
anzusprechen natürlich ist das Thema
Befähigung und vor allem eine gute
Balance zu finden zwischen
schutzorientierung und auch Teilhabe von
Kindern und Jugendlichen an digitalen
Medien auch mieterworks ganz ganz
wichtig und wird auch entsprechend
sozusagen ein großes Thema für die
Zukunft werden
gleichzeitig muss man auch da sagen
Alterskennzeichen können natürlich eine
Orientierung bieten sind aber kein
Allheilmittel also dieses Thema wie
können Kinder und Jugendliche
ausreichend geschützt werden ist
eigentlich vor allem auch ein Thema
sozusagen von Safety Design durch die
Anbieter Jugendschutz schon bei der
Entwicklung von bestimmten Angeboten
mitzudenken ein Thema das auch noch ganz
spannend sein könnte ist das Thema KI
gestützte Altersverifikation das heißt
per face und Gesichtserkennung auch
einen Kind einen Jugendlichen zu geben
identifizieren bestimmte ja Angebote da
auch sprechen zum Beispiel für den Voice
Chat für Kinder und Jugendliche nicht
zugänglich zu machen ja Jugendschutz
beides sein habe ich schon genannt es
geht vor allem auch darum eine digitale
Selbstbestimmung für Kinder und
Jugendliche zu erwirken dass sie
auszustatten mit Instrumenten damit sie
auch wirklich resilient werden in der
Medien Umgebung und natürlich auch
Maßnahmen in den Angeboten zu treffen
ja soweit erstmal der Überblick